what's your opinion on calisthenics
versus weights again for me both I like
them both you know with calisthenics you
get that endurance strength you get some
flexibility and some mobility out of it
they're pretty natural movements right
they're pretty natural movements are
things that you're doing with your human
body so they're going to be more natural
weights obviously make you stronger more
explosive at a certain point they also
can be more injury inducing and at
another point they're also less injury
inducing so there's a certain point
where if you have an injury in your
shoulder and you normally would do
handstand push-ups which means you're
lifting up 230 pounds well with weight
training you could lift up 40 pounds if
you want to right so so there's it goes
both ways where sometimes calisthenics
might be the more injury inducing thing
and sometimes weight training might be
the more injury inducing things that's
why you got to balance the two of them
you know and for instance when I if I
like I hurt my ankle a couple months ago
and I could not put any weight on the
scroll bar so I was just doing you know
pistols and and school you know air
squats jumps and box jumps you know I
was using things that war didn't have
anyway because I could do all that but
the minute I put weight on my back you
anything above body weight it started to
hurt and so I just needed to let that
thing heal and I used the calisthenics
to get me there and then the same exact
opposite
I had my shoulder was tweaked six months
ago and I was having a hard time doing
handstand push-ups because it was just a
wrong angle and so I was just using just
using I was doing press with a lighter
weight than my body weight in order to
keep the blood moving in court in order
to keep the in order to keep the system
moving because that's what I think you
got to do so I think you got to be you
got to find a balance of both which
means which means I'm not graded either
one of them I'm not
when in any weightlifting competitions
and I'm not going to win in a gymnastics
competition either and AH there are some
guys especially now I mean there's some
guys that are getting in sick shape you
know you watch the guys in the CrossFit
Games right now they're savages and
they're doing both the calisthenics and
the weightlifting and actually reading
something about it the other day and
it's becoming more weightlifting focused
you know whether it's a long wait what
is CrossFit CrossFit okay I shouldn't
say it's getting that more focused but
if you want to win the CrossFit Games
you got to be able to lift some heavy
weights you got to be able to deadlift a
lot snatch a lot clean and jerk a lot
and if you can deadlift a lot clean and
jerk a lot and snatch a lot you're going
to be able to do and at least you
practice the other movements the muscle
up the pull-ups you're going to be much
more apt to be able to do those things
than the other way around
mm-hm so I mean it's for somebody that
can do a bodyweight snatch is more
likely to be able to do 50 pull-ups in a
row then somebody that's able to do 50
pull-ups in a row and that's their focus
in life is able to automatically do a
bodyweight snatch I mean that's just the
reality of it that's what I think right
now but the bottom line is on those I
use both of them I like to try and find
that balance and I think I use both of
them according to what my body
prescribes me